foreign
[Music]
and for those of you who want to
automate queries I have good news in
this video we are going to show you how
you can use bigquery scheduling query
feature to run the queries anytime or
run a particular query on a recurring
basis for example to automate reporting
to begin with let's look at some
prerequisites first enable the following
apis bigquery API for your project and
bigquery data transfer service API
next ensure the users are granted with
the appropriate identity and access
management or IM permissions to perform
the tasks
to create the transfer you must have
bigquery.transfirst.update permission or
both the
bigquery.jobs.create and
bigquery.transfirst.getpermissions to
run a schedule query you must have the
bigquery.jobs.createpermission for the
project where the query will be run and
bigquery.datasets.update permission on
the target data set to delete a schedule
query you must have
bigquery.transfirst.update permission
here's a useful tip remember that the
predefined IM role bigquery.admin comes
with all the permissions required for
you to schedule and modify queries all
right let's now look at how to set up
schedule queries on Google Cloud console
go to the bigquery page run the query
that you would like to schedule and
verify the results in our example we
have verified the following query when
you are satisfied with the results click
schedule and create new scheduled query
option for name for the schedule query
enter a name for example my scheduled
query
next in the schedule options the query
is configured to run every day by
default however you can modify the
frequency to weekly monthly custom or on
demand not the on-demand option allows
you to run the query whenever you want
to run it at a later time for a custom
schedule use a crown like time
specification
we will retain the default option that
is to run the query daily you can modify
these settings to start and end the
query at specific times based on your
needs next set a destination table for
query results choose the right
destination data set for the data set
name enter the name of the destination
table in the table name before setting
the destination table partitioning field
let's learn about the partitioning
options supported
bigquery has two types of table
partitioning for scheduled query
destination tables tables partitioned by
ingestion time these tables are
partitioned based on the scheduled
queries runtime leave the destination
table partitioning field blank and
indicate the ingestion time partitioning
in the destination tables name with
syntax my table underscore run
underscore date tables partitioned on a
column these are partitioned based on
either time stamp or date column specify
the column name in the destination table
partitioning field when you set up
schedule query let's go back to the
Google Cloud console where we will
specify date for Destination table
partitioning field
under destination table write preference
select either append to table to append
data to the table or overwrite table to
overwrite the destination table we will
retain it as append to table remember
the destination data set table for a
scheduled query must be in the same
project as the scheduled query be aware
the data in the destination table is
encrypted automatically with the Google
managed key however if you would like to
use customer manage encryption keys or
cmek then you can choose CME care in the
advanced options in our project we will
use the default encryption optionally
you can choose to associate an
appropriate service account to your
scheduled query under scheduled query
credentials in our project we will use
default option user credentials and
leave this field empty
finally in the additional configurations
check send email notifications to allow
email notifications of transfer run
failures if you want to publish
notification messages to Pub sub then
specify the pub sub topic
the query has finally been scheduled now
that the query has been scheduled it's
important to note the following caveats
while using scheduled queries when you
create a scheduled query the time is
converted from the specified time zone
to UTC the offset between the specified
time zone and UTC can vary for example
with Daylight Savings Time DST schedule
times are not updated for DSD for
example a scheduled query created in the
summer to run daily at noon pacific
daylight time will run at 11 am Pacific
Standard Time daily in the winter unless
updated you can address this issue using
one of the following ways update the
schedule time between the last one
before and the first run after the DST
change create a separate schedule for
the bigquery jobs to be run during the
DST period
secondly when you run scheduled queries
in a region which does not match the
destination table region you will get
this error this is because cross region
queries are not supported in bigquery to
prevent this issue ensure your scheduled
query is run in the same region with the
destination table exists specify the
correct region for running your bigquery
jobs by passing the location Global flag
you can also choose your data's location
on the console under query settings
for supported region pairs copy data
from the source region to where the
transfer will be created
finally changing the credentials used in
a scheduled query to a service account
from a user account is not currently
supported in the cloud console it is
helpful to note that you can do this
using the following command in Google
Cloud CLI by using the flags update
credentials and service account name
well there you have it in a few minutes
you learned how to schedule an automate
bigquery jobs and considerations to keep
in mind while doing so to learn even
more about scheduling bigquery jobs
check out the following documentation
thanks for watching
foreign
[Music]